10 €, das Doppelte von 5 € und das
Zehnfache von einem Euro diese beiden
Beträge haben wir schon abgehakt in
unserer Serie einen Tag kochen für und
heute ist die 10 € Note dran das ist
schon relativ viel wenn man darüber
denkt dass wir es wirklich geschafft
haben für einen Tag mit einem Euro
auszukommen wir sind aber trotzdem
wieder im Discounter gestartet und haben
uns gedacht wir können heute einfach auf
eine größere Produktvielfalt
zurückgreifen und es wird bestimmt
relativ entspannt werden wir sehen ob
wir richtig gedacht haben wir sind auf
jeden Fall erstmal durch die
Gemüseabteilung ein bisschen geschaut
erstmal überlegt was können wir
überhaupt machen mit diesem Geld hat
Zwiebeln eingepackt die werden mir
sowieso brauchen dann habe ich
Spitzpaprika gesehen die habe ich
inspiriert zu einem Gericht welches ich
zum Abendessen machen möchte natürlich
darf auch bei 10 € keine Pasta fehlen
Pasta kann man immer essen so man kann
Nudeln machen war man kann Nudeln machen
kalt
man kann Nudeln machen warm man kann
Nudeln machen kalt dann brauche ich noch
gehackte Tomaten und Eier für das
Abendessen und habe mir noch einen simit
gekauft dann habe ich noch Thunfisch
gesehen aus der Dose und dachte mir ich
hätte Lust was damit zu kochen ich
möchte aber nicht den aller billigsten
nehmen dann habe ich mir eine Dose davon
gepackt und ich hatte wirklich schon
große Sorge ob wir mit dem Budget
überhaupt noch hinkommen erstmal bezahlt
und wir sind bei 7,39 € rausgekommen
also noch ein bisschen Raum ich brauchte
aber noch Erbsen die gab's für mich
nicht in dem ersten Discounter und wir
haben welche gefunden für 79 Cent die
Dose folglich haben wir noch 1,81 €
übrig und ich konnte zum ersten Mal
etwas fertig zubereitetes kaufen in
dieser Serie ihr müsst euch vorstellen
das was ich mir jetzt kaufen werde
kostet über 1 €, also mehr als das für
was wir einen ganzen Tag gegessen haben
und ich bin zum Bäcker gegangen habe
mich umgeschaut und da habe ich gesehen
Quark Kirsch Streusel und der hat
einfach 1,85 € gekostet also 4 Cent zu
viel es gab aber was für 1,75 das habe
ich geholt das habe ich hier hinten und
das ist mein Frühstück ihr habt gesehen
viel eingekauft deshalb ist so ein
kleines süßes Frühstück absolut im
Rahmen ihr merkt aber auch es sind nach
wie vor keine Getränke dabei das heißt
in diesem Budget ist man trotzdem nur
mit Leitungswasser bedienen 1 € 75
einfach einfach ein dreiviertel Tage
Essen das ist schon verrückt es lacht
mich sehr an ich würde mir aber auf
jeden Fall wünschen dass es keine
Rosinenschnecke ist sondern eine Kirsch
Quark ich hätte jetzt übelst Bock darauf
kannst du vielleicht ein kleines
bisschen
heute deshalb würde ich sagen ich weiß
ja erstmal hinein
machst du
Pan type da drin du bist ungesund aber
übelst das geile Frühstück hält nicht
lange satt muss es aber auch gar nicht
weil das Mittagessen ist eines meiner
lieblingsmittagessen und das im heutigen
Budget man muss wirklich sagen viele der
Entscheidung die ich heute getroffen
habe waren Luxus Entscheidung so weil
mir das hier zu kaufen anstelle von zwei
Brötchen und Eier hätte ich ja sowieso
noch übrig gemacht mir ein kleines
Rührei dazu zu machen ist halt einfach
nur weil ich mehr Lust darauf habe so
ich habe jetzt in diesem Budget auf
jeden Fall schon die Freiheit so ein
bisschen abzuwägen so worauf habe ich am
meisten Bock aber es ist trotzdem noch
nicht so die volle Freiheit also ich
kann auch nicht einfach sagen boah heute
habe ich Bock auf das und dann mache ich
das und man muss trotzdem noch gucken
wie man damit hinkommt aber es ist schon
sehr geil wenn man allein diesen Betrag
zur Verfügung hat man muss natürlich
dazu sagen es ist ja jetzt der gesamte
Einkaufswert wenn es für 9 € 94 €
eingekauft und davon haben wir ganz viel
übrig also es ist schon Zwiebeln übrig
Nudeln haben wir übrig Eier haben wir
übrig Paprika haben wir übrig schon viel
also daraus kann man easy noch mal noch
eine Paprika Pasta machen wenn man jetzt
so satt werden will beste Leben ich lass
mir schmecken und dann sehen wir uns
später oder wahrscheinlich relativ bald
zum Mittagessen
[Musik]
wir haben alles was wir fürs Mittagessen
brauchen
so sehr gut das sind unsere Zwiebeln
jetzt brauche ich eine Pfanne damit
hätten wir ein bisschen
Olivenöl jetzt geben wir ruhig schon in
die kalte Pfanne Zwiebeln viel mehr
Olivenöl werden wir hoffentlich nicht
brauchen wie auch die letzten Male setzt
sich so ein paar Sachen bisschen Öl
bisschen Salz Pfeffer voraus ein
Großteil des Öls können wir aber
hoffentlich aus dem Thunfisch ziehen
weil der ist in Olivenöl so wir wollen
unsere Zwiebeln nur dünsten nicht mehr
nicht weniger und dann schnappen wir uns
unsere Erbsen hier muss ich ein bisschen
Abstriche machen ich nutze da
normalerweise bei meinem Mann mir das
beigebracht hat immer gefrorene Erbsen
weiß nicht ob das auch irgendein Vorteil
hat auf jeden Fall waren sie zu teuer
weil die gab es nur im Kilogramm Paket
und das hat dann 170 gekostet wieder
aber in der Dose die sehen schon ein
bisschen anders aus aber das soll schon
sein vielleicht sind die frischer wenn
man sie direkt gefroren werden ich weiß
es nicht wir werden es am Geschmack
merken guck mal wie schön grün die so da
sind auf der Verpackung das ist wirklich
ein bisschen traurig
und Ernst gespannt wie das schmecken
wird du kannst Vertrauen man nimmt davon
ruhig viele
oh der Geruch war der Geruch ist schon
jetzt doch Kindheit für mich das war
wirklich immer willkommen in meiner
lieblingsfachwirts normalerweise mit
Käse oder auch immer komplett ohne aber
wollen wir nicht sprechen das tut mir
sonst zu sehr weh weil es geht
eigentlich bei vor neue peselli darum
dass man sich das mit Parmesan zu
ballert und dann drei Teller davon ist
aber Parmesan ist heute leider nicht
drin der kostet ja alleine schon Zehner
wenn man ein richtig guten Kauf das
sieht man nicht falsch aus es ist aber
ein sehr ungewohntes Bild ich glaube die
gefrorenen Erbsen ist jetzt ein bisschen
dumm aber welche da vorne Ärzten haben
auch dieses schöne grün also es ist
schon noch mal schon noch mal ein
kleiner und das geschmacklich
entscheidet ja merkt die Leute die hat
so gesprochen und kauf mir das Video
aber für 79 Cent welche aus der Dose
nimmst Ernst von Anfang an da fehlt auf
jeden Fall noch Öl und ich hoffe dass
der Thunfisch es uns geben kann bist du
so nett Herr Thunfisch oh ja besser auf
jeden Fall ordentlich Öl dabei das
schütten wir natürlich dementsprechend
nicht weg so wir unseren Thunfisch davon
wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall irgendwas
verschwenden dann wollen wir doch mal so
das Zupfen jetzt klein wir kochen unsere
Nudeln und dann verbinden wir das ganze
bei einer schönen frischen Pasta
[Musik]
let's go die Hochzeit von Pasta und Soße
sagt durchmischen so eine schnelle Pasta
so eine leckere Pasta dann mache ich mal
einen schönen Teller fertig und dann
lasse ich mir schmecken aber ihr merkt
schon dass eine familienportion
eigentlich schon wieder ne ich habe noch
Nudeln übrig ich habe sowieso Zwiebeln
übrig aber das ist halt eine Portion
nicht nur für mich also der sägt aber
schon das ist schon man denkt so okay wo
ist die Soße so ist die Pastasoße aber
durch das Olivenöl was ich am Anfang
hinzugefügt habe was aber auch bei den
Thunfisch dabei war hat man wirklich
sowas ähnliches wie eine Soße und es ist
wirklich wenn es denn gelungen ist eine
geile Pasta also
[Musik]
die Geschmacksnoten sind eins zu eins
und wie ich sonst immer mache die Erbsen
ein bisschen wenig bist weil ich halt
wahrscheinlich einfach zu lange in der
Pfanne hatte weil sonst immer mit
gefrorenen mache aber die Thunfisch Note
die Süße von Zwiebeln und Erbsen so
einen simples Gericht aber so lecker und
so anders als diese ganzen Standard
passt das deshalb macht es unbedingt
nach unfassbar lecker ich vermisse nicht
mehr so sehr den parmes wirklich sehr
sehr gut auch wenn das hier nur ein
dritte von der gesamtportion ist ich
esse das und ich bin packt so ich auch
erst ganz spät heute Abend wieder was
aber ich freue mich schon drauf wenn das
Gerät für heute Abend ist wieder eine
zehn wird sagen wir sehen uns bei der
Zubereitung von eben jene was soll ich
euch sagen Leute ich bin erstmal ins
Koma gefallen gerade nach dem Essen
wirklich so eine dicke Portion Nudeln im
Bauch bräuchte heute wahrscheinlich gar
nichts mehr zu essen umso besser dass
unser Abendessen schön frisch und schön
leicht ist wenn ich hier so seht habt
ihr schon Idee was es sein könnte ich
meine ich habe ja vorhin schon die
Zutaten genannt der ein oder andere mag
ist vielleicht erraten haben ich mache
shakshuka eine
nordafrikanische Schmorpfanne aus
Paprika Debatte das ist sehr köstlich
geht sehr schnell und die Hörer vom
Halle zwei Podcast wissen dass ich
dieses Gericht sehr gerne mag es gibt so
effiziente Wege eine Paprika zu schälen
und ich kriege die immer wieder erklärt
wenn ich im Video Paprika Schneide aber
ich mache es nie
so sieht das Ganze aus wenn es
geschnitten ist wir machen unsere Pfanne
heiß und wir geben die gerade zuerst
auch noch mal ein bisschen Olivenöl
hinein und dann beginnen wir unsere
Paprika zu garen wie gesagt bei 10 €,
ich mein wir haben sogar hier noch zwei
ganze Spitzpaprika die hier bewahre ich
einfach auch auf kann man noch als
Rohkost Fetzen was auch immer
so das kamen wir ein bisschen an zwiebel
und Paprika und dann können wir gleich
auch schon unsere Tomaten drauf geben
hier schon wieder duftet hier so kochen
wir das ganze ein die Feuchtigkeit ein
bisschen reduziert von den Tomaten jetzt
würzen wir das ganze magst du keine
Kreuzkümmel benutzen weil es gegen die
Challenge was sagt er hätte hier kreuzt
und ich könnte den benutzen das ist halt
auch so ein zu dieser charakteristische
Geruche aber ich werde ihn nicht
benutzen werde ich nicht machen freust
du dich schon mit deinem Zimmer drin
dort rein zu tippen oh ich freue mich
[Musik]
so jetzt soll das ganze nicht mehr
kochen wir gehen also unter 100 Grad und
wir formen jetzt vier kleine poolen für
die Egos hattest du das nicht für
paraplatte gemacht Bro das war das erste
Video weil ich für dich geschnitten
[Musik]
so dass mir das ganze jetzt vor sich hin
köcheln und geben dafür schon mal den
Deckel drauf
[Musik]
ich habe noch ein Tuch drauf gemacht
weil der Deckel nicht perfekt abschließt
aber so sieht das ganze jetzt aus auch
wenn alles noch ein bisschen flüssig ist
und so machen wir die Pfanne aus damit
es jetzt mit der Resthitze weitergab
sieht aus wie aus dem Lehrbuch sage ich
immer frisch aufgetoastet wir müssen uns
aber noch kurz gedulden weil das ist
jetzt gerade noch sehr rot und dann
lassen wir es uns schmecken brauche ich
mehr sagen nein wir haben ein frisch
getoasteten Semit welchen wir jetzt in
die shakshuka hinein Dippen welche schon
wieder eigentlich eine Portion für
mindestens zwei Personen ist und
[Musik]
sind wunderbar gegart die Tomaten
pappkarsoße ist sehr schön würzig der
Stolperer hat auf jeden Fall auch gut
getan also ist ein schönes Aroma noch
drin
[Musik]
aber schon fruchtig würzig es ist
einfach geil was lernen wir daraus für
10 € einzukaufen und zu kochen ist im
ersten Moment vielleicht ein bisschen
schwieriger als gedacht wenn man doch
ein bisschen gucken muss was man kauft
im zweiten Moment lassen sich daraus
aber wirklich köstliche Gerichte ohne
Verzicht auf irgendeine Form von Genuss
kreieren das haben wir heute gemacht ich
habe ja in den Kommentare was ihr
gekocht hättet und mit welchen Betrag
der das ganze als nächstes machen sollen
ich gönne mir jetzt dieses ehrenlose
shakshuka und bis zum nächsten Video